[Music] The
legend speaks
of Magamesa from the depths of darkness The
world will turn into hell The
destined
team will select six winners
and give them the power to save the world
Called a hero
[music]
Destined to divide without
pine
give me
[music
] queer
[applause]
[music]
den o
this nameless
uh
i am
[music]
hai yeah yeah yeah
[music] It's a
beautiful sister's game  Yo
me
[Applause]
I guess so, but
yeah, none, yeah, yeah,
here and now, in front of the great king and his subjects,
the semi-finals of the rookie ball will be held.
There is an abundance of rain
belonging to Tomaso, the country of fresh
greenery in the East.  It's a
fair and square fight, Won wants. The
winner is the previous winner.
What are you two doing?
My name is before Adlet,
the strongest man in history.
Drive out the grave over there
[music] yai nakashita [music]
[music]
tee
Char Sumino Dame
[music]
me
goo
today
[music] coming soon [music] 90 t [music]
tee
[music]
I'm
sorry, that poison must hurt Because your shoes were made of cloth
[Music]
How did you see it?
Ella Naked
san
A little bit of virginity
[Applause]
[Music]
dee Total
remorse 1 Runner
Holy martial artist 4 Let's mess up
Come loosely to Thailand
Hmm
ana I
found it
Part Red-san, right? Exercise in the
arena  I got to see you fight I was
moved
I became a fan of you
Please shake my hand
I'm a maid I only do it
sometimes  I'm a child who wants to
know about
[Music]
Adlet Naya 18 years old
Born in 8 countries Incense burner Uwanashi's name is Atros Biker
Atros Spiker
At the age of 10 When I left the bridge and went to the market  For a
long time, I spent all my time in training to beat the demon god in the mountains
.
I feel like I've heard the term "strongest on earth" for the rest of
my life.It's an unshakable fact that I'm the strongest on earth
.
I'm
better than
you There are a lot of strong people in the world, of course
Dar believes there's no one stronger than me
That's all, isn't it?
The god of fate also knows Art is just teaching the devil and people around the world You
're really confident.
What happened to the Envelope Club
Ah, the
match was held again yesterday.In the
semi-finals, Kuwata-san won by a small margin.In the finals
, it was a landslide victory.
I hear you hurt your shoulder when you
were thrown.  So,
Mr. Hato Red
, do you want to be the hero of
Rokka?  In
this world, you
can be a mermaid or a
mate.1000 years ago, a
monster appeared on this continent.It was
called a genie and began to attack
humans.It simply killed people and cut its own body into pieces with
Kyoma.  I created a new monster called
, and killed even more people in the
Great Hygiene Empire, Loha.  The
empire was destroyed, and the royal family burned down the towns and villages they wanted.
[Music]
People despaired and accepted the fate of destruction
.  With the flower in her hand, she was called the one-wheeled saint.The
long, long battle continued,
and she cornered Jin Fujima of West Java Island to the western end of the continent and
defeated her.
is not dead One
day he will wake up again and return to the land of the world The
living have prophesied that when the
genie awakens
Six heroes will appear who will inherit my power
They will drive the genie back to the depths of sleep once again  The
one who is going to be chosen as a hero is a temple built by a single saint to enshrine the god of fate
.  The coat of arms floats,
so people call those six heroes the Rokka
Braves.It was 700 years ago
when the Rokka Braves appeared for the first time in this world.
a 3
6 soldiers Anju
And beside the demon,
they attack
Maa.
Politics at the time of Marley, the saint of blades
Yes Merlania, the saint of thunder
Prefectural forces Roy because of Bodoro
, the saint of salt Manya-kan, the saint of salt Although the
heroes made sacrifices, they finally sealed the genie
300 years have passed since their last resurrection
And so, over the past 10 years, there have been numerous appearances on the continent today, and the
Bible Fukumori tells us that there are cracks in
the prophetic rites.  Selected as 0
You will defeat the demon God
Knight of the Fire Prevention Country Do you know Mr. Lauichita
?  I
guess I was killed Roco strengthened Probably I'm hexagonal in preparation for the resurrection of the devil
But even today, it shouldn't be easy to defeat them
I think it's better to stay here until the injury heals
This  The security of the country's loans is very strict, so the maid sneaks in and heads off to Kita Makar
[laughter]
.
I'm going to get scolded If you meet a princess, tell me.I'm sure you'll be chosen as a rocker
Murder
, smell of apples,
Adlet It's sweet, but the reason for imprisoning you
is undecided.
My mother thinking about jailbreak
[music]
What's with that voice today?
ana
[music]
Rokka's fierce general summons The
temperature is good It
's a quick one Hey, Oe Everyone has a lot of things No, I was chosen as vodka Why is there such a place and it's over I'm in a hurry
I don't do java  Please,
let me introduce myself again. There's
a Shetani, there's Piena Augustrone, a country's first princess,
and it's because of the blade of the same university.
Let's buy a copy
I don't have it
Applause]
[music]
debian
me
[music]
[applause]
a
No one can catch up
yet Leave it as it is and head for a hideaway
Sorabe is the land of philosophy,
and the peninsula on the edge
Well, it's a rule that things gather at the entrance of the national territory
.
[music] me haha ​​[music]
me
[music]
wh
ah ah ah
next
first trip
me yeah yeah
yeah
[music]